you know i'll be honest with you all my
life i've seen the sun
and just like you guys i have a question
for you guys
made it seem like i was they're the only
ones that really hurt is that i have a
question what yeah so like when you
watch like you don't get emotional or
like feel thankful or have some sense of
like feeling of gratitude when you see
like the sun rise or the sun go down
you're just kind of like sunset like it
doesn't like you're not in awe
i think i forced myself to being on with
it because everyone else
so it's like you know if no one told me
how great it was like i was the only one
living on planet earth yeah i probably
wouldn't know what it was
but since people go i've had like i've
i've eaten at restaurants with people at
like five yeah
inside and they're like let's go out to
the patio and look at the sunset
and i'll go
yeah
you really want to go bobby have you
ever seen the flash of light
yeah
what have you ever seen the green flash
of light right before the sun goes down
i've seen it i've heard of this
and i thought that everyone was lying to
me my whole life but i saw it for the
first time last week and i screamed
wow at the very last bit of the sun when
it goes down yeah it like puts out this
like green orb this green flash oh wow
and yeah i've never seen that like that
wow no no yes that one this does that
that's exactly at gilbert what is it
what is it i just called you gilbert
gilbert gilbert what is it
but the bottom the second to the left on
the bottom
right there
that one that one that's exactly what it
looks like
wow
yeah i've never seen that
i want to see it we got to see one thing
we got but when i see a sunset i look at
it and i go
i i kind of look at everyone's cues yeah
so people go oh
you follow so i'll go
you know what that means
what
i'm a sociopath when it comes to sunsets
specifically specifically sunsets i
think that's what i have yeah yeah i've
never cried over anyone you cry over
like i don't cry over my brother your
dad you didn't i didn't cry when my dad
died
you know what i mean i don't cry
in that way i cry
when i don't expect it because here's
the thing i know when i'm expected to
cry so my head already immediately goes
why aren't you crying you should be
crying even though you feel like crying
do it right oh you're a crazy person
right so when i'm watching something
like when my brother came over and we
saw that um
in and of itself again yeah and my
brother started crying i cried we cried
so hard
like composing crying like my brother
went like this
he went like that
like that and i was like
right and we were like deeply crying so
i'll cry like indirectly i have the
emotions but i don't tap into it like
when i'm supposed to because it's like i
feel like there's some sort of like
pressure to do it or whatever yeah but
have you ever like
had have you ever said goodbye to
someone and felt like a tug at your
heart and feeling like oh
like i'm gonna cry like when you say
goodbye to your mom or you know i felt
that the other day when charlie
he knew he moved oh yeah i bumped into
him at the gym yeah he's in idaho he
went to bed and so the the i didn't talk
to charlie in three years
you know have you talked to him when i
text you that photo no oh yeah i said i
said i we taxed but i haven't really
talked to him yeah so when i've talked
to charlie i know you have yes so we had
dinner at the chinese restaurant and
when he said he was leaving
there was a real sense of like
oh it sucks you know
you know i mean there was a sense of
crying almost
but i didn't
you know because in my head i'm like
i'll see him again you know
and he's you know i'll be honest with
you too
and this is gonna sound crazy when my
dad died
it's almost as if he's not gone and i'll
see him again i have this
weird sense that i'm going to see
everyone again anyway who do you think
we're going to who do you not want to
see again that's passed away who's
passed away so it's kind of like um
it's like i kind of don't like that idea
because it's like
it's like lost who you who do you not
want to see at that church at the end of
lost yeah but i think that once
you see them again even somebody that
you hate right i don't know what realm
it's going to be i don't i don't want to
call it heaven but it's like in the next
phase
right i think it's going to be like oh
that was crazy you know hitler
i think he's going to be like they're
like hey guys my bad might be
yeah yeah i played it wrong wrong i
played that wrong you know i mean and we
were like yeah man cheers not cheers
like that was weird man
yeah you mean he's a big i know dude my
bad yeah it's like i don't know if i can
like we already know each other i feel
like everyone knows each other
and at the the next realm
right we don't just we don't right now
know that we know each other right but
when we go to whatever the next realm
we're going to see dudes and go like
jeffrey dahmer is like shouldn't hate
those guys dude that was weird he's like
i don't know what happened man why are
the asians yeah yeah they just you guys
are so delicious and trust me he tries
to make a joke like that i think nah
dude that was weird right and then maybe
see you yeah yeah maybe i'll give a half
hug
you know what i mean like you know you
gotta get a shoulder hug right you're
like later and then you might see dudes
that you like really admire right
you know cleopatra do you admire her
well you know she's legendary right no
maybe not her um let me think somebody
that i admire i was like would i oh one
of the authors that you love to share
mufuna probably maybe yeah
shiro
hey dude i go i didn't get to see you
you know and everyone understands each
other without like their own language
yeah we we all speak one language i love
it what
what do you love it i love the idea that
you just you speak in your language but
everyone understands yeah
yeah it's like one of those um language
simulators that they do in star trek
like in star trek that the last star
trek i don't know that right the last
project movie the last star trek movie
one of the villains in it right she
spoke a different language but she had
like a little mouth apparatus she spoke
her language into this mouth apparatus
and it translates it you know meaning to
whatever language i like that yeah yeah
what are you doing
nothing
yeah but i think that we're gonna see
each other in a realm i think we knew
each other before too
and so when people die i think
i really do believe that i go i'm going
to see that a guy again or it's
nothingness who cares at that point yeah
yeah you know either way
it's all just a
sweet it's just a game it's not go there
it's not a game yeah it's meaningful
it's full of love it's full of love and
game
game like activity it's not game okay
speaking of game would you guys like to
challenge each other in a squid game
all right but do i have the stand not to
stand this was a simple one it's our own
version is it covered friendly because
we're friendly it's a question this game
is called the thing is is that or the
thing is is this
and you're gonna be asked a question and
you have to pick
either of the answers okay
let's go basically i would like to
practice